déjà mme horwath adrets plaisir de
pouvoir excessif
merci à certains qui me font penser à la
mer aujourd'hui partager mon expérience
avec lui et comme ça et on peut aussi se
trouve aujourd'hui je pense que j'ai la
lourde tâche de représenter la gent
féminine donc que je n'aimais gpa loup
et il y avait donc pour l'ag j'ai déjà
travaillé en traite à l'âge de 21 ans
j'ai diplômé d'une école de commerce et
j'ai rejoint conduite a raté à langoat
quand on a beaucoup parlé à travers son
fondateur et président pendant quelques
temps donc j'ai rejoint microsoft et
donc quand j'ai rejoint du procès en ce
moment plusieurs années j'étais focalisé
sur ma carrière j'avais envie d'avancer
j'avais envie de voyager leur permettait
d'aller un peu partout dans l'agréable
aussi de découvrir votre pays auquel
j'avais eu la chance de l'année et donc
je suis focalisé sur sa réalisé avancé
avoir de nouvelles positions j'en ai
plein d'objectifs je veux ici at-elle
acheté l'âge et beaucoup ça a plutôt
bien marché pour moi
sauf que en 2006 j'ai eu
j'ai eu ma première fille mia et est
donc là j'ai commencé à me rendre compte
que ce que c'était un challenge
maman qui avait il y avait un travail
qui étaient investis pleinement
professionnellement et qu'il voulait
aussi jouer pleinement son rôle de
parent premier challenge et en même
temps à ce moment là je commence à me
rendre compte qu'il y avait quand même
quelque chose qui doit entrer c'est vrai
j'avais un super boulot j'avais ma 6 mai
et où quelque chose qui manquait et
c'est vrai pour moi je me suis dit mais
quand j'étais plus jeune on était
adolescente s'était beaucoup de choses
qui me passionnait et c'était plus du
tout aux bistrots que je ne suis pas un
sport j'ai touché un peu à peu avec un
petit penchant pour l'adaptation mais
j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de le rejoindre
un club de natation et est au contraire
je passais à la fin de la journée je
m'asseyais sur un petit mur au club où
j'étais et je regardais les nageurs
faire des allers retours se préparer et
parler de championnat et c est moi
j'étais là et je regardais et mais bon
heureusement j'avais go sport poursuit
essayez un peu aux arts martiaux et
voilà pour ça que j'ai tout ça est donc
je vendais mes 6 ans n'ayant eu ma fille
j'y suis dit et c'est dommage c'est
dommage de gérer tout ça entre
parenthèses est ce que c'est vrai
situé appris la veille travail et c'est
peut-être le bon moment de reprendre
pourrait dire aussi que j'avais une
bonne motivation parce qu'après vingt
mouvements ou leurs 18 kilos en plus oui
on va encore nous motiver à reprendre le
sport est donc j'étais mariée vous
débarquez par la course a donc à ce
moment là c'était devenu après la fête
et semi marathon et qui vont la course à
pied c'est pas trop mon truc mais mais
je les garde
j'ai commencé j'ai compris c'est que ce
départ raté et puis en 2 clics
je suis tombée enceinte de man et sa
fille leila et j'ai cette fois je me
suis dit bon hors de question que je
laisse tomber de strasbourg choquant il
est clos et donc je me suis remise à la
vache on passait évidemment c'est
beaucoup plus ou moins dangereux et donc
j'ai repris le plaisir j'ai repris de
geos répond en fait à faire des
longueurs et à une dans l'eau et au même
moment c'est que me souviens c'est
savoir à quelles conditions autour d'un
dîner avec
il y voyait des moyens peuvent entraîner
et qui est utilisé mais foot tu es dans
matrix qui est vrai que ma paroisse
dehors de la chose et tout ça dès que
des bruits patrons devraient penser à
faire quelque chose dans la natation le
tiers ne traversait pas des droits de
gibraltar gt3 ces deux continents
c'est traverser la méditerranée et je
dis ok je le regarde avec mon ventre et
j'ai tout laissé c'est sympa mais ça
c'est du pur délire et donc j'oublie
j'oublie le sport de détroit j'accouche
te vas des âmes fille et je comprends
que la course à pied donc je reprends
avec la course à pied on est passé du
seuil des moratoires la vôtre des
marathons et de l'ultime kilomètre et
vival et les super seniors à tous et
donc je en 2010 je cours un premier
marathon à marie et léger à dorothée
j'ai appris parce que je vais faire
moins de kilomètres et des poussières
ce qu'ils sont importants et bien on
attend de faire le tour de vous refaire
le monde et surtout de faire autour de
soi même de vraiment dire intérieurement
notre eau spéciaux et et de repartir
avec plein de choses et puis surtout en
tant qu'amateur c'est fabuleux quoi de
travers
courir dans closer est arrivé de
traverser arrivé d'avoir des gens me
soutiennent et qui vous partez vous avez
une renaissance vous savez parfois aussi
vos détails
je trouve ça fabuleux là je me suis dit
fais quand même c'est vrai que c'est la
cgt je me suis dit là où vivent les
sports d'endurance pour moi je suis
petit c'est quand même dommage de rester
dans la course à pied alors que quand tu
es plus jeune parce qu'il faisait vibrer
c'était de voir des nageurs en train de
faire le con coeur etc
et comme vous l'avez si bien dit
effectivement il ya un enjeu c'est trop
tard de départ mais nous le dit vivre
pour faire carrière dans la natation aux
professionnels c'est trop tard mais je
suis sûr qu'il doit y avoir quelque
chose d'équivalent or un rapport à temps
pour voir le temps la passion et donc je
prends ça fait une petite recherche et
je découvre le monde de vos livres
donc je découvre qu'on peut nager dans
des rivières ou petit j'ai tenté de la
coupe évidemment manche caché en mer qui
peut participer à des courses comme semi
marathon et marathon
on sait bien organisé il ya plusieurs
personnes etc
et je découvre aussi peut vraiment
traversé le détroit de gibraltar à la
nage et qu'on peut faire même plus à ce
moment là il ya même eu un jeu
extraordinaire qui s'appelle diana nyad
qu'il ya 60 ans a fait un truc de chichi
extraordinaire entre la nage et entre de
cuba qui ouest
pendant plusieurs jours sans l'effet à
60 ans après avoir tenté une fois encore
échoué à trois et a réussi à vous la
cinquième bon je me suis de ces travaux
je vois je peux faire quelque chose pour
ça donc je ne soutiens pas le style des
trois sauf les armes les faubourgs le t3
et je rencontre aussi je la sens de
chance aussi de rencontrer un jour un
ami qui m'est très cher qui s'appelle
stimulée notamment par atria keïta qui
au matin je souhaite grand succès aux
jeux olympiques de rio
et donc on fait quelques longueurs en
fin de matinée mais vas-y détente et non
pas je me suis cru bon ok je vais tenter
et donc je me dis que je vais aller
chercher conseil auprès des mots et des
experts le libre dans l'eau et donc je
fais dans un forum de l'open space est
un marathon quand on a acheter c'est 10
km donc l'équivalent des 42 km quant aux
courses et à 10 km à la nation et donc
je peux type d'éclairage et la manche
écrit bonjour je les suivais tp peine je
suis une chose après quatre ans quand je
suis une maman de deux petites filles
géniales genre à plein temps avec des
responsabilités
je n'ai jamais nagé en mer à part
barboter évidemment à la blache d'été et
maximum dans une piscine
ces trois kilomètre en kilomètre
et je veux traverser le détroit de
gibraltar et la mairie dans ce confident
je me suis tu vois tu le mets en taule
wave asie bravo et courage
j'ai entendu et le jour où j'ai reçu les
mails cet été maintenant si vous voulez
travers sept et trois quatre cinq fois
batterie par cinquante cinq
entraînements par semaine avec
obligatoirement est donc sortie en mer
mais moi je peux moi j'allais me tran
anh on valoir dans ce cas laisser tomber
c'est autre chose vous donnez à
l'intercepter et là j'avais des francs
je veux dire effectivement c'est soit
j'ai enfin l'impression de quelqu'un
d'autre et qu'on me dise oui où ils
peuvent asie tu peux le faire
soit j'ai vraiment envie de faire ce
truc là et je fais ce qu'il faut pour y
arriver
et heureusement j'ai choisi la deuxième
en dessous et donc je ne soutiens pas
c'est pas grave on oublie on va oublier
les bourreaux de l'eau libre
c'est vrai que donner son nom et
nationaux en outre à l'irma demain une
saison où ils ont l'habitude de nager en
eau tout ça et qu'on analyse et
d'angleterre entre et donc le détroit a
traversé detroit et détenu à projets est
devenu un vrai projet qui tenait à
cannes avec justine on va maintenant
j'ai besoin d'un plan b
au même moment je peux en train de
changer en fait d'orientation
professionnelle donc
j'ai quitté la boîte j'ai rejoint donc
la demande va rentrer dans lequel je
suis aujourd'hui 10 pour créer le
département marketing et communication
donc beaucoup plus de challenge
j'étais attendu parce que sabres qui en
pleine expansion nous avait beaucoup
d'attentes et en baissant jamais de vie
qui est en train de grandir et ils leurs
besoins grandissent et avec ça
compliquait revue l'équation est donc
justement c'est mal il faut un plan
continue-t-il devons d'abord construire
l'expérience rgo conseil parce que
c'était donc j'ai pris mon petit sac à
gauche alors d'espagne le week-end et
pour jeunes s'inscrivent dans une course
de 6 km pour savoir ce que c'est déjà
relégué heureusement j'ai découvert que
j'avais mal de mer quand je me réjouis
donc il fallait qu'ils puissent trouver
une solution avant d'aller sur une
distance un peu plus grand plus fort et
stable d'implanter à cherchait pas à
chercher des personnes qui ont fait la
même chose et à essayer de comprendre
comment commence plupart des gens
passionnés et et a voté dans un lycée
j'avais jamais le fier j'avais monde et
comme tout le monde j'ai vu leur
habilité j'ai des faiblesses et à côté
j'ai aussi des valeurs avec lesquelles
j'ai grandi qui peuvent paraître
évidentes mais qui pour moi sont
essentiels
cette fin à dire mais c'est essentiel
j'ai grandi en général on le travaille
et des valeurs de la nidation que j'ai
vu à tous les jours à travers à travers
ma mère mon père m'a toujours dit mais
si tu veux quelque chose qu'il faut
travailler pour ma mère est atteint il
faut choisir
quand on veut quelque chose il faut
laisser aux il faut prendre les actifs
et agréé stenhouse aviez des gens
évidemment n'avait jamais cherché une
rencontre mais vraiment extraordinaire à
travers ce sport donc les gens un peu
partout dans le monde mais aussi des
gens au maroc qui m'ont portée qui m'ont
soutenu mais vous avez aussi des gens
qui vont nous envoyer les zones et dati
est ce que j'ai répondu souvent mais
écoute comprendre tu as un super job
souffrir challenge qu'est ce que tu vas
être ajoutés des choses avec le détroit
qui maintenant il me rend les concentre
toi sur tes filles ou bien si tu veux
vivre pleinement sa passion et l'esprit
tout ça et il va vivre sa passion combat
à faire des trucs dans la natation mais
moi je n'ai jamais rien dit parce que je
suis ni une femme enfant mis à manager
ni passionné de livres
je suis vinet 3 et j avais pas envie
d'être encore cette petite fille ou sept
jeunes je trouve si petit que ça cet
adolescent qui était sur le mur qui
était frustré parce que je disais
et eux ils sont ravagés au sénat j'ai
envie d'être alors que je passais sur
sur le leader et donc j'ai décidé donc
de laisser beaucoup tomber aucun des
trois les choses qui tenait à coeur
d'aller casser je continue à prendre le
petit déjeuner avec les enfants aller au
bureau a permis aux entreprises et moi
je pouvais entre métiers de bouche
quelques mois je rentrais je vous avez
deux mois avec les enfants c'est
important pour moi et je retiens rien la
piscine à leader du périnée j'allais
nager j'ai rencontré un vendeur et
lendemain rebelote
et c'est vrai que par moments c'était
que parce qu'ils vont finir par moment
cette étude est de concilier tous à part
mon rang c'était même désespérance
d'idées c'est vrai pourquoi changer tout
ça et c'est là où on s'y met moi je
préfère parce qu'il ya quelque chose qui
m'apprend un peu plus approchant risquer
quelque chose qui t'attend et et au delà
de ça ces valeurs pour lesquelles j'ai
utilisé avec lesquels j'ai grandi et
aussi tous ces gens qui vous jésuitique
ont soutenu mais vraiment pas la tête
il y avait même si ma famille c'était
devenu un projet avec ma famille avec
les gens qui étaient proches jean ticket
chez un rockeur était devenu un projet
commun et je sais aujourd'hui clairement
que si je n'avais pas eu de ressentir
j'avais jamais vaincu d'avril dernier à
8h38 je me serais jeté à l'eau pour
vivre un moment un des moments les plus
exceptionnels j'ai pu vivre jusque là
donc là je martin
j'ai eu quelques photos et les images
défilent
[Musique]
à moi
moi
[Musique]
qu'ils soient
moi je
[Musique]
pourri
oui
m
[Musique]
seafrance
ah ah
[Musique]
j'suis tous
ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà j'ai vu un moment fabuleux parce
que voilà c'est parti d'une histoire
très personnelle du derby de combles
étaient peut-être une frustration donc
juste d'arriver à quelque chose peut
être aussi un peu de vent de la neige
et puis je pense que en tant que
marocaine et je pense que c'est quelque
chose que beaucoup de marocains partage
et je pense que c'est quelque chose qui
est en nous et très très fier d'être
actrice est attaché avec pelli est
arrivée sur les côtes marocaines en
agence et existe un sentiment encore
faible et est en fait qui est ce que je
ne savais pas en faisant ça parce
qu'elle dérange vraiment ce qu'il est
costaud partie de l'étude en vie
personnelle c'est que ça m'a ouvert les
horizons des juste incroyable ce qui
m'arrive mais après cette traversée
franchement je ne pouvais même pas
l'imaginer horaire encore en 2008 le
fameux peut pas baser métier devrait
traverser au moins j'ai rencontré des
nains en gérant j'ai rencontré plein de
gens qui vont parler y est vous le dire
j'ai d'abord ces histoires de j'ai des
amis noirs un peu partout dans le monde
avec son incroyable même si vraiment ça
va ouvrir les horizons pas ce que ça va
donner envie de développer avant plus ce
sport est de donner envie peut-être à
d'autres personnes des pratiques c'est
vrai que ce n'est pas préfet encore
suffisamment bureau maintenant qu'à
l'encontre d'un dépôt de magnifiques et
donc de qu'il rêvait revenir je
travaille avec des organisatrices du
premier événement du livre a par là et
avec qui les publient pour on attire
aujourd'hui plus de 15 nationalités
105-100 une centaine de personnes
l'année dernière et 150 personnes s'est
abîmé saint-jean suis très très fier et
puis ça m'a aussi ouvert notre
perspective c'est de le travailler dans
un domaine différent en tant que
bénévole pour un travail a été gérée et
c est donc finalement je me dis c'est
vrai que c'était il y avait 2
la difficulté des sacrifices mais ce que
j'ai reçu en retour est bien plus
important que ce que j'ai pu sacrifier
pendant quelques heures en quelques mois
et étaient pour finir je dirais un peu
comme vous mes prédécesseurs en jeans et
c'est je pense pas qu'on soit quand on
vit encore complètement son fils moi je
pense pas tout ça les personnes
particulièrement extraordinaire
je pense qu'on l'ait tout ce que tout
homme à ce potentiel bien enfouis qui
demandent juste ça va être révélé et
pour ça qu'il faut évidemment rester
ouvertes c'était parfois ce n'est un mot
ces deux rencontres qui va aider à faire
sortir ce potentiel
mais surtout il pense qu'il faut
s'accrocher à une valeur qui peut avoir
une fois par exemple et s'assure que de
prendre les cantons lucratif et c'est
vrai quand on croit dans la persévérance
dans dans la méfiance dans
et positive s'approcher mais aussi
d'humilité parce que c'est important
pendant ton parcours va rentrer on ne
peut trouver des solutions nous trouver
sa voie il ya des réajustements la
fameuse image aux 60 ans qui a réussi à